one of president Trump's accusers is
trying to subpoena recordings of Trump
from The Apprentice yeah however Trump's
legal team has refused citing attorney
meatloaf privilege so that's to say that
was founding fathers put that in there
yeah president Trump's former doctor is
now describing himself as frightened and
sad experts say that's a common reaction
to touching Donald Trump's prostate
[Applause]
the only guy that eats a cheeseburger
during his prostate exam I'm the mine
who explains things rudy guiliani has
joined trump's legal team exciting yeah
i don't know what that means
White House insiders say that President
Trump feels comfortable with Rudy
Giuliani because they're from the same
generation yeah
Giuliani says we share common values
like hard work patriotism and ditching
your first two wives
that's just something
hurry it up new study came out new study
reveals that the best way to add years
to your life is to exercise lose weight
don't drink too much
to which yet to which all of America
replied what else you got no interest to
anyone
a man in Kansas this is not a lie a man
in Kansas was arrested after trying to
have sex with the tailpipe of a car yeah
he's being charged with finding
something to do in Kansas
in his defense it was a rental we've all
done it with a rental come on got three
people to go it's true that Honda Civic
and I had a good time you know
you